i am thrilled to be able to call him a
friend and now a guest of the rich eisen
show here on the 32nd anniversary of
pete rose being banned for life in
baseball is the great keith olbermann
how are you
well i just had to knock dan over rich i
mean he was getting on my way and i had
to roll him over and my dad was in the
in the audience sorry i just couldn't
resist no problem
no so dp is the ray fossey of this uh of
this analogy right there
well he would not say that
how are you doing kale how are you i've
been banned enough time so i think my
buddies
work doesn't it
never occurred to me before it was like
why am i sympathetic to pete rose oh
[Laughter]
so uh tell everyone where you were 32
years ago today
from bart jamadi's announcement of the
suspension banishment of pete rose by
happenstance i was working in los
angeles i was the sports director at
channel 2 and it was summer nothing
going on vacation i was home leaving
friday morning was a friday uh to go
back to l.a and thursday night the story
began to break that this press
conference was going to take place
through the plans into reverse went with
the local crew from channel 2 here in
new york and was at that press
conference and you know i mean it's a
historical moment we see it as like a
flash there's two points of importance
one that story had been building up for
a year
i have a vision of myself standing
outside spring training with the angels
in 1989 holding up sports illustrated
with the beginning of the end of pete
rose that was march so every day that
summer until this time of the year it
was pete rose this pete rose that you
know four years after he broke the hit
record and this was i i this would be
the acc the equivalent of i don't know
banning ohtani in four years or
any other huge baseball figure uh and
the second part of it was bart giamatti
and i said it on the air that day and i
still haven't gotten over this
was the most alive i ever saw anybody
anywhere the day that he banned pete
rose and a week later he dropped dead of
a massive coronary artery still just the
the most forceful
righteous indignation he was vengeance
uh as as justice
and and most just the most alive person
i've ever seen do anything and he was
gone a week later an extraordinary week
so um what was it like in that room
keith 32 years ago today there was there
was there was bart jamadi and the rest
of us were just kind of just kind of
watching this
uh orchestra conducted by a man by
himself i mean he was he he had the
whole thing prepared it was clear from
his phrasing based on what we're hearing
out of cincinnati that he had
somehow convinced pete that this was
a reviewable suspension and a temporary
thing maybe a year or something and then
in fact he had slipped the noose around
pete's neck uh and and and did what we
have seen since which was a lifetime ban
without really ever calling it that but
it was so
dramatic and rarely do stories in any
line of life in my 40 plus years of
covering this stuff stories that have
such a long buildup i mean there were
rumors of this in 88 i first heard
something about pete rose and gambling
in 1980
out of the memorabilia business
and it took all that time to build up
and yet this was like i can't compare
the this to anything else of that kind
of long buildup this was lightning this
is a series of lightning strikes only
the man standing at the podium was
throwing the lightning that was what it
was like keith olbermann here on the
rich eyes and show 32nd anniversary of
the uh
bart giamatti press conference
announcing pete rose being banned for
life ko was at that
press conference so the sense was at the
time
that that pete would have a chance to
come back or no no i think the sense was
that uh pete thought he was going to get
a chance to to come back and a lot of
the
ill will between pete and baseball i
think really originated with the idea
that that
they they i don't know if they didn't
read the documents close enough or pete
didn't understand them or what happened
but jamadi was going for a permanent
ineligible ban i mean his last words
were the subject of pete rose is closed
uh and i think the the the from later in
the same day when they put those
questions to pete he was like no no it's
going to be reviewed in a couple of
weeks and that's the whole i mean he
believed he was signing some sort of
admission in exchange for leniency and i
guess the leniency was he was only
suspended for one lifetime rather than
through 25
but jamani was was
clearly furious at that news conference
and and suppressing rage
and it contributed to the to the nature
of the uh of the forcefulness and and
many people thought it contributed to
bart's death too because the whole the
entirety of his commissionership was
essentially
consumed by dealing with the rose
scandal as it built and built and built
and that was
uh you know if you tie this into the
idea that's also sort of lost to history
bart jamadi was considered to be the man
most likely to save baseball from itself
he was a
president of yale a scholar and a
baseball addict and a red sox fan when
that meant you can endure losing wrote
poetry about baseball and who was
probably the most over qualified
baseball executive of all time and he
was coming in he was going to clean
things up and the first step was you
know oh pete rose thinks he's going to
sue me go ahead
try it and that was his attitude he was
going to say the same thing and had the
same things to owners and we haven't had
a commissioner in sports like that there
have been some good ones like adam
silver and a few others who have done
okay but commissioners are toadies who
are um management employees say vincent
would have banned like 16 owners if he
had excuse me jamadi would have done it
vince had tried
barchamadi would ban 16 owners if he'd
had 20 years in the commissionership so
there's that second element to it as
well besides peace so then i guess that
might answer my next question keith
olbermann which is if if jamadi had not
passed away a week later you know how
stances soften over time right so
do you think the fact that jamadi
passed and then there are people who are
close to him who do believe that the
the rose
scenario uh and situation led to his
um uh heart giving way
that that if he had lived that maybe
rose might not be banned for life today
no i don't i i think that uh regardless
of of what the consequences were i mean
obviously bart jamadi died because he
was a was a chain smoker and uh and his
and the other things that that brought
stress or pressure to him could have
been interchangeable with things that
did or did not happen elsewhere in his
life i mean you can you you can control
i'm i'm recreating i sense a sense of
this must have contributed to his
strength
who knows but i will say this i don't
think that that there would have been
much of a different path for pete under
a long-term jumani commissionership
because again there had been
in that year
many threats from the rose side like
don't you dare try to i mean he's the
most popular man in baseball which might
have been true
um he's the most famous player in
baseball he broke that bastard ty cobb's
record uh i i think
jamadi was was believed that the entire
power structure and the rules that he
most believed in as in no gambling
uh certainly no gambling on your own
team passive aggressively or otherwise i
think he believed rose was not only
violating them but challenging them and
challenging essentially the rule of
baseball law and nobody was righteous
like bart chamadi put a lot of people
off
but it endeared him to other people
because he he was that hard on himself
and people that he liked as well as
people he didn't like but it was a
personal struggle between these two men
and bart chamati died thinking he had
banished pete rose for life and i think
it would have stayed that way and what
about rose's demeanor towards all of
this i i had mentioned earlier and i
wonder what you think about it keith um
that
had rose taken the approach towards
gambling and uh made himself the face of
the scourge
of gambling similar to what mantle did
about alcohol and how it can tear away
at your career and your family and it's
not for everyone and don't do it
had rose taken that approach do you
think he would still be banned today on
that front uh i i i'm
really conflicted about the answer to
that because you could just as easily
ask the theoretical if pete had laid low
for a long time and then came out as the
face of baseball friendly gambling which
the leagues have now endorsed uh maybe
he would have been restored that way
you know uh the the the attitude towards
this entire topic has done a 180 in the
last uh 20 years maybe longer really it
started with the acceptance of uh
fantasy baseball as kind of a low-grade
uh
uh gambling form which i often indulged
in as you may remember yes but
um you know it's it's such a strange
uh
what's moral and what's immoral it
changes every few years in in many
different areas i i don't think
i i think pete went through periods of
time in which he was really remorseful
and was was showing an understanding of
what happened and was trying to atone
and i thought he should have been left
off the hook and then oh by the way this
stuff with underage girls came out that
was the end of it but they did you know
the commissioner's office had to sign
off on pete rose going back to fox for
baseball postseason coverage so he did
in fact get back into the game and there
was a path for him to go further back
into the game and maybe even have that
ineligibility lifted in some formal way
it had been to my mind it had been
lifted informally pete rose was not i
mean you can't be banned from baseball
and you know be on the freaking post
game show the world series so that's not
that's you know
it's it's like the joe jackson band
we're going to celebrate shoeless joe
jackson every year now in dyersville
iowa but he's still officially banned
and nobody should do what he did brought
to you by draftkings it's kind of a
mixed message now
keith olbermann here on the rich eisen
show what about the sense of the fact
that cooperstown is a museum
as much as it is a shrine to the greats
and placing
on a plaque
the whole story as best you can fit on a
plaque and put pete in uh for what he
did
on the field what about the sense of
that
well you're now asking to to do
something subtle in one of the least
subtle places in in the world which is
the baseball hall of fame i mean if you
wanted to do that their their means to
do it tomorrow
stratify the hall of fame into echelons
you know the all-time immortals or
whatever you want to call them which
would be ruth and aaron and josh gibson
and 20 people or whatever and then
there'd be everybody else who reached
certain statistical plateaus and other
people who got voted in and and infamous
people who you know ruined their own
lives and careers and you could have a
essentially the hall of fame members who
were
uh bad guys if you want to have barry
bonds and and pete rose over in one
section with schulich joe jackson and
eddie seacot and and and george hall and
jim devlin from the 1877 louisville team
that threw the pennant that year you
could do that too but this is you know
this requires a lot i will point out as
is often i think mentioned about pete uh
the best part of the baseball hall of
fame is the behind the scenes tour that
you can usually get if you know somebody
and in a room downstairs next to the 37
degree photo
uh vault
is the uniform vault and i forget how
many pete rose uniforms are in the hall
of fame right now but i believe it was a
dozen and that by the way
uh the uniforms is how we knew something
was wrong because when you could not
collect baseball uniforms because teams
did not sell them or distribute them uh
in the late 70s and early 80s you could
always find a game used pete rose
uniform and the story was he needed so
much money for something gambling was
the rumor that he used to buy the
uniforms after he wore them in a game or
two and would sell 20 or 30 uniforms a
year and the joke was collector goes to
the dealer and says i want a pete rose
game used uniform and the guy goes
uh cincinnati montreal or philadelphia
and the fan goes uh cincinnati he goes
home or away
like uh home uh 60s vest style or big
red machine pullover uh uh pullover
please okay what size
and that was that was nice that's
literally that 1979 1980 so we sort of
saw this coming so that circles back to
the idea that pete rose is in the hall
of fame
uh as shoeless joe jackson is in
baseball's marketing strategy it's such
a complicated subject which would be
made a lot easier if they just said hey
this is a complicated
subject
the rules been now and again we're going
with this one this year and we'll see
what happens next year a few minutes
left here with keith olbermann on the
rich eisen show i would be remiss if i
did not uh finish up uh with this
because you referenced him
uh to try and i uh imagine uh place in
perspective for those who might be of a
a little younger than than us keith to
try and play some perspective what
banning rose felt like back uh in the
day 32 years ago you invoked the name of
shohei
ohtani
i would be remiss if i did not give you
the floor to try and place in
perspective of what we are seeing
from him this year keith oliver all
right well there's i'm this is not a
criticism of his work nor a a
diminishing of what he has done it is
almost unprecedented for the time
um that we're living in in which
the the key is specialization he is a
generalist and this is an extraordinary
thing i will point out there was a 19th
century pitcher who one year led the
league in earned run average and the
next year was the batting champion so
these things have happened in history
with two-way players before i would say
that i would like to see
a little bit larger body of work not
that there's anything that suggests this
isn't going to continue but i'd like to
make sure that it's more than just a
couple of seasons before it's
you know he's the greatest player of all
time well no babe ruth is the greatest
player of all time because he did this
he had a hall of fame pitching career
and then hall of fame record-setting
hitting career it's early and my biggest
problem with baseball right now it's
true of all sports is whatever just
happened if you phrase it correctly it's
a record
that's the most homers and wins by one
guy on a thursday in the middle of
august and people take this dead
seriously and people get credited for
pointing these things out and i just
like to the greatest baseball pitching
season of all time
was by harry kraus of the 1909
philadelphia a's and nobody knows who
the hell he is his first 10 starts in
1909 he threw eight shutouts ten
complete games we don't know how many
earned runs he gave up but it may have
been as few as two and those were his
first ten starts
then he hurt his arm and the next year
is pitching for portland to the pacific
coastline and i'm not saying that's
going to happen to show hey otani i'm
just saying please give me a little bit
more context before i assess him amongst
the panoply of all-time greats because i
heard this all year all spring from
friends of mine like gary cohen about
how jacob the gram was the greatest
picture of all time was like can you
just
can we just get to the all-star break
without his arm
nobody will do this now no matter what
the sport is it's whenever i turn on
coverage of the nba or nfl it's the same
thing it's like he's the greatest player
of all time he came into the league
three weeks ago and and and i'm only
being slightly hyperbolic about this
let's just
assess something at the end of the
season it's extraordinary it's something
out of in terms of comps you have to go
to the 19th century to find anybody who
was this good at both things
um even for this period of time because
ruth of course was a pitcher
small transition period about a year and
a half then basically just to hit her
uh so it's remarkable and it it's it's
it's hall of fame trajectory but it's
really early all right so that's the
long-term view what about let's just
place it in 20 21 box is it most
valuable is he the mvp of the al
um by by almost every definition of it
other than the fact that the angels are
once again not in a pennant race and if
they were you know maybe trout would be
injured for the playoffs which would be
transport trout's luck right uh other
than the contending quality that you
like to see in an mvp yeah i mean i
think it should be unanimous at this
point for the simple reason that once
again when you say who's the greatest
baseball player of all time at least in
american and nationally context we don't
have a full picture for the players who
did things similar to this in the negro
leagues but in the american league
nationally context
what what exactly who do you compare to
babe ruth who was
in his time perhaps the best left-handed
pitcher of the game and then became a
hitter the equivalent of whom now would
have to hit something like 150 homers in
the season
so when there is a guy who could finish
at 50 homers and double digit wins as a
pitcher
um you know just the 50 home runs might
get him the award but if you throw that
added little you know free song of
excitement that is oh yeah he pitches
and wins and i i speak as somebody who
was utterly skeptical of this when he
came into the american league uh yes i
would say that he's the he he if he were
to sort of go home for the year or not
play again or whatever for the season i
think still yeah this performance is
most valuable player because it's it's
it covers candidates
and wipes out it wipes out most of the
other hitting candidates and it holds
its own against most of the other
pitching candidates kale this was
awesome i i as i had hoped and expected
and and greatly appreciate and you know
of course i know you you were into
rotisserie baseball and fantasy baseball
i'll just let everybody know uh when i
was the intern for the cbs evening news
in the summer of uh
1994
uh eric sorenson who was the executive
producer of the evening news one of the
first tasks i did was to
uh make copies of the one uh report from
the weekly report that was mailed to him
for a fantasy or rotisserie baseball
league and as i uh copied that for eric
i noticed the name on it of one of the
members of the league keith olbermann
and uh i immediately asked eric how do i
get in touch with him can i send a tape
to him and his uh end of the summer
present to me or at least kudos to me
was to actually send a tape to you keith
and that's how i first got in touch with
you ever correct correct with one
insulting detail
of course
as usual
i sure yes sir was the commissioner of
that
so i ran that league so then and yes how
did i get copies oh wait a minute i
opened his mail for him
and saw that it came from you now i used
to compile the stats yes put them out
weekly when this was still a novel idea
when you couldn't just buy stats from a
stat provider and i would fax them
i would fax them from my home near espn
headquarters world headquarters in in
bristol connecticut
fax them and then put a copy in the mail
in case somebody needed a hard copy we
did the standings to the standing red up
to the minute state of the art stats
once a week
okay thanks in that league and we in
fact we used to have the
the auction was by coastal because most
of these guys in this league were with
me in los angeles in local sports and we
would have um by coastal auction where
some of the owners would get together at
la tv station and sorensen and me and
the one-year mike tarico was in it we
would get together on a saturday morning
in a board room at cbs
at cbs tv and we would have this thing
to get on a speaker phone and conduct
this option
with all these guys and yes and and then
eric's called me up one day
hey i've got some money for him
uh eric was great to me eric gave me all
sorts of money eric bought me two or
three houses
i'm still waiting on that but he hooked
me up with you and i still speak with
him and
and i'm uh uh thrilled that i i still uh
can you talk to people used to make
really bad trades with me another reason
i like them very much take care of
yourself ko thank you for the call
i really appreciate it thank you that's
the one and only keith olbermann right
there on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here